first of all Emilia Clarke just walks up
in here and shows everybody how it's
done to kill the game I just thought
sparkles mid-sentence yes they do by the
way we saw the birthday reunion you had
with Kidd and Jason I was that getting
everybody together again that game of
Thrones I know it's really good we're
all really good friends still and so I
had a birthday party and I was like
who's in town
and it's just I mean I'm best friends
with kits wife rose and they live
literally two doors down so I seen them
on the regular but Jay was in town and
it was yeah magical we were having the
conversation today has anyone had a
better on-screen situation than you like
all of your own I know I've done very
well I was really sick and I nearly died
I don't tell people cuz they get weird
but I don't think you'll get wet no you
know earlier you were really brave
talking about your real life health
scare that you had in the movie your
character also has to help scared did
you draw from what you were going
through in your real life yeah yeah hard
not to we had we both have medical
dramas around the same time in our lives
there was a huge amount of Kate Street
there kind of reflected my own truth as
well we deal with them in slightly
different ways and my liver is still
intact but yeah it was it was there was
observer some cross so just a for sure
and we just got the news stay at the
Game of Thrones prequel is canceled did
you hear that as they've just heard that
today I know I know I'm not really too
sure I mean I suppose this is reflective
of the state of our um you know it's
difficult to get people to go and see
stuff and it's difficult to get stuff
made and I just I wonder maybe you'll be
reincarnated at some point but if it
wasn't meant to happen now
so it's because they knew it wasn't
gonna be as perfect as it should have
been
so I heard you say like Emma Thompson
was kind of your soul mate
I said that to her yesterday she's like
she's damn straight yes you guys are
kind of homies now your stuff so tell me
about the sleep
exercise not at all
alcohol oh she's like the pirate no ok
fine thank you doctor thank you so much
for your time let's go man see it's
absolutely my saw my I am is so blessed
and bill of gratitude for Emma Thompson
big in my life
[Music]